If you've ever been interested in getting your own personal genetic
information and done any searching online, then you've probably come across
a company called 23andMe. And in this lesson, we're fortunate enough
to have a co-instructor, a representative from 23andMe join us, Joanna Mountain.
>> Thank you, Matt. I'm excited to be here.
>> It's great to have you. Now, can you tell us
a little bit more about 23andMe and, and what you do there.
>> as a geneticist at 23andMe,
I'm involved in the research, where we try to link
the DNA with particular traits and diseases. We also I've
been involved in developing the tools and the features that
help people understand their health and their ancestry through their DNA.
>> Now when was 23andMe actually started or founded?
>> Yeah, the company was founded in 2006, and we launched the
service in 2007, the year I joined. and that was the first time
it was possible for people to really explore this
hidden dimension of themselves. Something that was, was hidden from
everybody And it was a brand new opportunity for
people to learn about themselves through looking at their DNA.
>> And this sounds like a pretty exciting revelation for
most people. Is this something that's available and accessible to everyone?
>> anybody who has internet access can sign
up and start exploring their DNA. And the
cool thing is, I remember the first time I
went snorkeling, and I. It was just mind blowing to
me, be able to, you know, discover a whole new
world within the ocean. And to me DNA, to be
able to explore your DNA is similar. You just,
it opens up a whole new world of, of things
to learn. And it's, it's a very personal world, it's,
it's you. And that's this is something that's was not
available 10 years ago.
>> Well, I think I know just the group of people who might be interested
in learning a little bit more about their genetics. So let's go chat with them.
>> Great. Let's go!